welcome to Baskin Robbins would you like
to try our mango fruit blast uh no
thanks
um I will have
a burger please oh we don't
we don't make that pretzel hot pretzel
like mustard mustard dipped ice cream
basket rub
I'll just do like whatever's hot and
fresh
can I see in the back Chief Pronto sure
thing Dale
Darby could you just uh take care of
this idiot thanks
hey Dale come on in pull up some chair
three years at San Quentin huh you found
out Baskin Robbins always finds out okay
I'm sorry all right but I
no one would hire me breaking and
entering grand larceny look I'm I'm
sorry I you know it was I I don't do it
anymore I just trying to respect
I couldn't be happier about it really
yeah yeah oh thank you thank you you
really stuck it to those billionaire
sobs the more I read about what you did
and stuff I'm like wow I know this guy
I'm in charge of this guy hmm well I'm
very happy in this job and I'm
I really just appreciate the opportunity
wow you're fired of course I mean
can't really keep you on wait what fired
yeah Dale look it wasn't a violent crime
I mean I'm a good worker no it wasn't a
violent crime it was a Cool Crime I'll
tell you what though this should be
totally off the books off the records
but if you want to grab one of those
mango fruit blasts on your way out the
door I'll just pretend I didn't see it
all right